Daily Mail has this dozens of US
government workers will stage a one-day
hunger strike to protest the bid
administration's support for Israel amid
the war with Hamas members of feds
United for peace told the guardian that
employees from over two dozen government
agencies including the Departments of
defense and state plan on a day of
fasting on Thursday I really find this
inspiring I'm so inspired that I would
love to see like 80% of the federal
Workforce participate in the Hunger
Strike
[Music]
indefinitely I mean if one day is
inspiring and it is imagine how
inspiring a month would be what about
second breakfast I'd love to see 80% of
the federal Workforce go on a hunger
strike for a month I think that's going
be the most inspiring that's the most
likely to bring about world peace and
they should do it